the opening ceremony of the Winter
Olympics is underway right now in South
Korea athletes from around the world are
marching into Pyeongchang Olympic
Stadium with their nations flags the
United States is represented by 244
athletes in a historic moment the sister
of North Korean leader Kim jong-un shook
hands with the president of South Korea
Ben Tracy is in Pyeongchang Ben good
morning good morning so the Olympics
sure has a way of bringing people
together inside this stadium you have
the vice president of the United States
and the sister of North Korean leader
Kim Jong hoon 28 year old kim yo-jong
arrived here in south korea today she is
the first member of North Korea's ruling
family to visit the South now earlier
today vice president Mike Pence toured a
South Korean naval memorial and met with
North Korean defectors he brought with
him the father of American college
student otto warmbier who died last year
after being released from a North Korean
prison the vice president said the u.s.
and South Korea are united in
confronting the North Korean regime but
South and North Korea are marching under
a unified flag at the opening ceremony
it shows the outline of the Korean
Peninsula a majority of South Koreans
oppose using that flag there have been
daily protests here and some people
we've talked to say they're upset about
not seeing South Korea's flag paraded at
the opening ceremony of its own Olympics
but of course for the athletes this is
all about the competition and the first
medals of these Olympic Games are up for
grabs tomorrow and everything from ski
jumping to speed skating Nora alright
Ben Tracy and Pyongyang thank you